[Music]
john kerry gives us the scoop that
sleepy joe's out of the loop
yes carrie does damage control in france
while biden wanders around without pants
[Laughter]
walking driftwood sculpture john kerry
says president biden wasn't aware that
the trilateral agreement between the u.s
the uk and australia would anger france
maybe because it wasn't french
the deal sunk a 40 million submarine
contract between france and the aussies
and france temporarily recalled its
ambassadors to the u.s and australia in
response an angry joe biden immediately
recalled our ambassador to atlantis
[Laughter]
just kidding joe can't recall anything
but anyway apparently old joe had no
clue the deal would piss off the french
ex
president biden asked me about it and i
told him and expressed
you told joe biden that it was not the
right he asked me he said what's the
situation and i explained exactly uh he
wasn't he had not been aware of that he
literally literally had not been aware
of what had transpired and i don't want
to go into the details of it
why bother at this point
before hopping in his private jet that
runs on panda blood
kerry went on to say that the u.s and
france have bigger world issues to work
on together such as cyber warfare and
climate change and if they're worried
about lost income kerry recommends
marrying a rich widow
so you can continue to fly on private
jets
because that's what he did but then they
concluded the interview with this
fascinating nugget
sure international diplomacy is
important and you know i think climate
change is the crucial issue of our
lifetime
but not as crucial as greg gutfeld
becoming the king of late night what
he's been able to accomplish in such a
short time is as incredible and as
beautiful as the eiffel tower don't you
think
they think who knew carrie was a secret
fan of the show thanks john but as for
bind being unaware of the deal that
seems odd at the very least right joe
look look look i am on top of things
right i know what's going on
it's just that this this submarine deal
was confusing first of all where i come
from we call them hoagies right
second of all
i mean it's you got a u
u s
u k e u there's too many letters
right
i gave it to carrie
he's good at the alphabet i mean
he looks like a muppet
get it it raises a question what else
does joe not know and when did he not
know it
yeah well
politicians say that all the time well i
didn't know or you didn't know in this
case i believe it
but i also don't know if that inspires
confidence if we're trying to be you
know getting along better with france
have confidence in us that he has no
idea what's going on why would you
bother to talk to someone who doesn't
know what's going on
i've tried it doesn't work very well yes
you know uh professor uh do you think
the democrats actually like it this way
the less joe knows the better it's hard
to know but you know john kerry the
operative words were i explained
literally unaware he's always this
pontificator right remember when he was
during the election
and he said if you don't educate you're
not educated and go to college we're
going to send you to iraq it's like that
was the worst of all fates and we
remember during the trump administration
he was always freelancing
on the iran deal meeting iranians so
it's always that he's the hero
and the intellectual master of everybody
so yeah it was probably true that biden
didn't know what was going on but kerry
so exaggerates his own role remember he
went over to china about
climate change and they put him in a
room and said later
and uh so he's always the legend of in
his own mind to be fair china thought he
was actually a cabinet
another great uh example is him going to
france after the terrorist attack
bringing james taylor i remember because
that was his that was his way of being a
hero right yes they're gonna love me
because i'm gonna bring james taylor
which no one has ever
said before david
david um are you aware of what's going
on in your razor company
is joe biden i don't know where i am
right now i mean i
joe biden obviously is confused that's
not news yeah we've known that what i
find interesting is france
the home of the paris climate accord
is like
we need to sell our diesel subs
[Laughter]
but i prefer the i prefer the french
submarines you know because they got the
ashtrays in there
[Laughter]
no torpedoes they just fire baguettes
that's what that's what they do it's
true yes and everything is done in the
uh form of mime
mime beside the yeah it's silent that's
a it's a very silent sub they paint
hands on the fence
it goes through the water
we should probably stop this
oh it shouldn't have started yes
mercedes um
do you do you think uh carrie is just
stupid or was was trying to trying to
throw the president under the yacht
carrie wants to be in the news he wants
to be relevant again so my theory is
that he must have said let me just throw
the president under the bus so that i
compare like i am the smartest one right
in the room
but when he did mention that you were
king i'll just say it in spanish
wow what do you think
pretty good huh
we have no idea if that's what she said
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else